بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
ان الله تعالى يقول
الايه التاسعه
والعاشره
سوره الحجرات
وان طائفتان من المؤمنين اقتتلوا فاصلحوا
بينهما
فان بغت احداهما على الاخرى فقاتل التي
تبغي حتى تفيء الى امر الله
فان فاءت فاصلحوا بينهما بالعدل واقسطوا
ان الله يحب المقسطين
انما المؤمنون اخوه فاصلحوا بين اخويكم
واتقوا الله لعلكم ترحمون
تقول تعالى
وان طائفتان من المؤمنين اقتتلوا
طائفه
بلغه العرب
هي الجهه
والطائفه
بالخصومه
هي الجهه التي تكون مقابل
للجهه الاخرى المعاكسه المضاده
فكل جهه مضاد يقال لها فكل جهه مضاده يقال
لها طائفه
الطائفه يصدق
اطلاقه على الفئه والجماعه
ويصدق
اطلاق هذه اللفظه على الفرد
فاذا كان شخصا واحدا
لكنه في جهه معاكسه مضاده لفئه اخرى
فهذا يصدق
اطلاق لفظ الفئه عليه يقال هذا فئه
حتى لو كان شخص واحد ضد
جميع من في الارض فيقال
فئتان
والفئه
والطائفه
المقصود هنا الطائفه الطائفه
يصدق هذا اللفظ اطلاقه على الفرط وعلى
الجماعه يقول تعالى وان طائفتان من
المؤمنين
يعني في اقل الاحوال
تكون طائفتان من المؤمنين
اقتتلوا لكن قد يكون اكثر من طائفه قد
يكون اكثر من
اكثر من جهه
لكن المقصود هنا وان طائفتان من المؤمنين
اقتتلوا
حتى لو
كان شخصين اثنين
لقطعت الى اثنان من المؤمنين
فهذه الايه
تنطبق على هذا المعنى
اقتلوا فاصلحوا بينهما اقتلوا يعني دار
بينهما القتال والخصومه
والمقصود بالقتال
الحرب والبغي
ومد الايدي
يقول تعالى فاصلحوا بينهما
وفي هذا ايضا امر
بان
يسعى
المؤمنون في الاصلاح بين الاخوه
قبل ان يصل الى حد الاقتتال
فاذا راينا طائفتين من المؤمنين
اخصين فما اكثر
الواحد شكل طائفه
واصبحوا
قاتلين
وهذه المقاتله قد تصل الى مد الايدي فاننا
نسعى
في الاصلاح بينهما قبل هذا
هذا امر في غايه الاهميه
لكن يتاكد
طرديه هذا الامر
انه اذا حصل بين المؤمنين فتنه حصل بينهم
خصومه فانه لابد
لبقيه اخوانهم ان يقوموا بالاصلاح بينهما
يقول تعالى فان بغت احداهما على الاخرى
الباغي هو الاعتداء
تجاوز
تقول هذا باغى على هذا يعني تجاوز في
حدوده
ووصف الله سبحانه وتعالى البحرين
قال لا يبغيان يعني لا يدخل هذا البحر في
حاجز هذا
والباغي هو الاعتداء على حقوق الاخر
باليد والمال
بعرضه فهذا اعتداء وهذا باغي
يقول حتى تفيء الى امر الله
فالمقصود هنا حصل القتال بين طائفتين
جاء المؤمنون فقالوا
لا تقتلوا
ولنصلح بينكما
مصلح بينهما بماذا بكتاب الله سبحانه
وتعالى بحكم الله بقضاء الله
فان امتنعت طائفه عن هذا
او ابت او لم تتقيد بالقضاء
فهذه تعتبر طائفه باغيه
وانه ينبغي على
المؤمنين ان يقاتلوا التي تبغي حتى تفي
يعني ترجع الى حكم الله
وهذا حق واجب
جعله الله سبحانه وتعالى على
جماعه المسلمين جماعه المؤمنين ليس له من
ينظر الى
طائفتين من المؤمنين مقتتلين
مقتتلتين
فيمتنعون عنه
التدخل يمتنعون عن الاصلاح بينهما هذا لا
يجوز
وهذا
ما كان من
امر
بعض اشياء وقعت فيه عصر الصحابه رضي الله
عنهم
بين
اهل الشام واهل العراق
في خلافه علي بن ابي طالب رضي الله عنه
ثم طائفه باغيه على الاخرى
لكن صفه البغي
المقصود بها الحكم
على هذا الراي
حكم الله سبحانه وتعالى حكم الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم على
قضيه
هذه الطائفه فقال باغيه
فقال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم سمى
طائفه من هاتين الطائفتين فئه باغيه هكذا
لفظ النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لكن هذا لا
يعني الذم
وانما يعني
الحكم على
على منطلق هذه الطائفه
واما الحكم على الشخص هذا امر اخر كلهم
صحابه
ونحسن بهم الظن
واجتهدوا
فالمجتهد بين اجر واجرين
ان اجتهد فاصاب فله اجرا وان اجتهد فاخطى
فله اجر واحد
فاجتهدوا
اجتهدوا علي بن ابي طالب اجتهد غيره من
الصحابه
فدار القتال بينهما
وكلا الطائفتين معذور عند الله سبحانه
وتعالى
بايات من كتاب الله وباحاديث من سنه رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم صحيحه لكن النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
اقتل عمارا
فئه الباغيه
فوصف هذه الفئه دون هذه
بالبغي وقال صلى الله عليه وسلم
قاتله
اولى الفئتين بالحق هكذا
يعني الخوارج لما خرجت
ونبتت نابته الخوارج بين الصحابه
فان الذي
قاتل وهذه حصلت فتنه الخوارج حصلت متى على
حين افتراق وفرقه في امه النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
كان عندك طائفه من المؤمنين
منعوا عن المبايعه وطائفه اخرى بايعت
واستقر الامر
على مبايعه علي بن ابي طالب رضي الله عنه
وطائفه من المؤمنين امتنعوا عن هذه
المبايعه
بانهم ارادوا
ان يتم القبض على جميع من
اعان على قتل عثمان رضي الله عنه قبل
المبايعه فحصل الخلاف
الهما على حق
لكن
ليس هذا يعني ان
اليه ما كان
كان
حقيقا بما فعل
مكانه كان طائفه مجتهده وطائفه مجتهده
فهذه اصابت في اجتهادها فثبت لها اجران
وهذه اخطات في اجتهادها فثبت لها اجر واحد
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وصرف
الطائفتين في صحيح سنتي صحيح البخاري
وصفه كلا الطائفه كلا الطائفتين وكلى
الخصمين وصفاهما
بصفه الحق فقال اولى الفئتين بالحق
هذا الذي حصل بين
صحابه
لم يمتنع جل الصحابه وجل المؤمنين على
التضامن مع علي بن ابي طالب رضي الله عنه
في مقاتلته
للفئه الاخرى وهذا كان الواجب عليهم
الواجب على جميع من علم الحق في ذاك الوقت
ان ينضم الى اولى الطائفتين بالحق لماذا
لان الله يامر يقول
فان باغت احداهما على الاخرى فقاتلوا التي
تبغي حتى تفيء الى امر الله وايش المقصود
المقصود انت فيئه
يعني ترجع الى امر الله ليس المقصود قتلهم
قتل قد يحصل لكن ليس هذا مقصودا المقصود
ليس
الاستئصال
القتل والسبي لذلك في هذه الاحوال
في الحرب الذي يكون القتال الذي يكون بين
المؤمنين اختلف اختلافا كليا عن القتال
الذي يكون
بين المؤمنين واعدائهم من الكفار كيف ذلك
فانهم لا ياخذون منهم الغنائم ولا
يلحقون من فر منهم ولا
يتابعون من ادبره ولا يجهزون على الجرحى
ولا
ولا تسبى نساؤهم
وذارابيهم لماذا لانهم
مؤمنون وانما المقصود ان يرجعوا الى الحق
اما هذه الاشياء التي ذكرناها قد تصح
ويصح وقوعها في قتال المؤمنين واعدائهم من
الكفار فانه قد يحصل هذا
لكن مع المؤمنين يختلف القتال لان المقصود
ليس الاستئصال ليس القتل ليس هذه وسيله
الى منتهى
وانما الغايه المراماه
انت في هذه الطائفه الى امر الله
يقول تعالى فان فات
فان فات
فاصلحوا بينهما بالعدل واقسط
العدل
واقسط
فلا بد من المعادله
كل طائفه تاخذ بما لها من الحقوق
قد تكون
احدى الطائفتين
اظلم من الاخرى قد يكون هذا لكن
قل له مظلوم ياخذ بحقه وهذا يكون بالعدل
والاقساط
والقسط
القسط في لغه العرب رد الحق الى صاحبه
رد الحق الى صاحبه
وفرق بين المقسط والقاصد
وفرق بين
القسط
والاقساط
القاسط
هذا هو الظالم هو اخذ الحق من الغير
هذا ضد
المقسط المقصد هو اعطاء مال للغير له واما
القاصد فهو اخذ مال الغير منه وعدم اداءه
حقه
فهو يقول هنا سبحانه وتعالى واقسط وهذا
فيه رد
رد الحقوق عندك العدل العدل في القضاء وفي
الحكم
وعندك الاقساط
لابد ان يقسط
ويقسط بينهما فترد الحقوق الى اصحابها
يقول تعالى ان الله يحب المقسطين
ثم قال انما المؤمنون اخوه
فاصلحوا بين اخويكم وفي قراءه فاصلح بين
اخوانكم
وفي قراءه اخرى فاصلحوا بين اخوتكم
هذه القراءات تدل على ان
ان هذا الحكم
ينطبق على
الخلافه الذي يكون بين
الاثنين فما اكثر
لا يجوز
ان نجد
اثنين من اخواننا متقاتلين متناحرين ندعهم
فيه حالهم
هذا لا يجوز
ولا يجوز
ان نعرض عن هذا الخلاف ونحقره ونستحقره
قول
هذا دوننا لا ما دام انه خلاف واقع بين
اثنين من المؤمنين فانه لابد من
لابد من العدل ولا بد من الاصلاح ويقول
انما المؤمنون اخوه
فاصلحوا بين اخويكم
يقول تعالى ان الله يقول تعالى واتقوا
الله لعلكم ترحمون
فواضح ان هذا
هو
من تقوى الله سبحانه وتعالى وواضح من
الاسلوب ومن اللفظ ان من اعرض عن الاصلاح
بين المؤمنين
ممن يجب عليه هذا
فان هذا خلاف
تقوى الله
فان هذا ليس من تقوى الله سبحانه وتعالى
مهم جدا ان نفهم هذه القضيه هذه قضيه
وجوب كفائي
وجوب كفائي ايش يعني وجوب كفايه
يعني واجب
عين على كل واحد
من المسلمين انه يتدخل فيه قضيه بين
مؤمنين لا وانما واجب وجوب
كفائي اذا قام بهذا اهل العلم اهل الحل
والعاقد اهل
الجاهه اهل
فان هذا يكفي الباقين
فانه ينبغي الاصلاح بين الاخوان
واذا
اعرض الجميع عن الاصلاح بين الاخوه فان
الجميع على الافراد اثم
هذا هو حكم
الوجوب الكفائي
هذه مساله مهمه جدا وذلك الاصلاح يقول
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ويامر سبحانه وتعالى
بالاصلاح بذات البين
وهذا
وهذا امر
بضد هذا يعني لم يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى
امتنعوا عن مقاتله بعض امتنعوا عن اذا بعض
نعم هذا صحيح لكن كمان لابد ان نسعى سعيا
في الاصلاح وفي اصلاح ذات البين
هذا امر في غايه الاهميه
لمجتمع يريد ان يكون مجتمعا مرضيا عند
الله مجتمعا قائما
بحكم الله سبحانه وتعالى واما مجتمع قائم
بغير حكم الله فانهم لا يعبئون بهذا وانما
يسعون في الاصلاح بين من بين من يعظمونهم
واما المحققرين في عينهم فانهم لا يسعون
في الاصلاح يستحقرونه ويستحقرون خلافاتهم
واما المؤمن فان المؤمن يصلح بين المؤمن
ويعظم جميع ما يكون بين المؤمن لانه
لانه عباده لله سبحانه وتعالى كل ما بين
المؤمنين فانه عباده من خير او شر
فاننا نسعى في الاصلاح ناس عى في التعديل
نسعى في
القسط
لا يجوز لنا ان نعرض
لا يجوز لنا ان نعرض عن الخلاف الذي يكون
بين المؤمنين
ولا يجوز لنا ان نعظم
بعض ما يقع بين المؤمنين من الخلاف ونحقر
بعض ما يقع بين المؤمنين من الخلاف لا
نسعى جاهدين انفسنا في الاصلاح بين
الاثنين وهذا يحصل كثيرا تجد هذا كثيرا
ان
ان نكون نعلم انه بين اثنين
شيء
وبينهم امر
ولا
يسعى من يرى هذا النقص في تعديله
وممكن ياخذوها شغله ضحك يعني
شو بينهم يعني انا قصه سهله
هذا امر ليس سهلا ينبغي ان يتحاب المؤمنين
وهذا الذي يكون بين الاثنين من الخصومه قد
يمنع من رفع عملهم
جاء في الاحاديث
ان الاعمال ترفع الى الله
ويغفر الله سبحانه وتعالى
للجميع الا لي المتخاصمين
ويقول
ارجوا ارجوا هذين حتى يصطلح
في مساله
يلقي لها بالا الله سبحانه وتعالى رب
السماوات والارض يلقي ونحن
في غنى عن هذا ونعرض ونضحك
مساله مهمه
لان هذا يؤثر في عباده الله سبحانه وتعالى
ونكمل غدا ان شاء الله الله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين